when people come here illegally and when
they break the law it's important that
we make that distinction that's what
we're doing with our rwanda policy
that's what we're doing uh with uh
making sure that asylum seekers can't
just vanish and vanish into the into the
rest of the country
let's cross live now to our politics
correspondence in westminster rob powell
and rob this isn't going down very well
with campaigners who will no doubt have
this at the forefront of their minds
during next week's next month's court
hearing on the legalities of the rwanda
policy yeah because of course it comes
uh it's really just this is really just
one part of a broader push a broader
crackdown as the government sees it
on people arriving
predominantly in small boats on the
south coast of england but also through
other irregular routes like on the back
of lorries across the channel tunnel
as well this is a 12-month trial this
tagging
pilot which started earlier in the week
it will only operate in england and
wales
and it will mean people could be
electronically tagged
if they come to the uk by what the
government says a dangerous or
unnecessary route so realistically
you're talking about on small boats or
on the back of lorries
the aim as you heard the prime minister
saying there is partly to ensure people
don't just disappear into the country um
when they're released from detention
centers where there's close monitoring
and released into asylum seeker
accommodation where there is a lot more
freedom the aim as well though is to try
and keep track of people and whether
they break any bail conditions or curfew
conditions they might have
and to find out whether more frequent
contact with people awaiting claims
can help to get those claims processed
um more quickly now we don't exactly
know who will be put into this 12-month
pilot but we are told that it won't
include under-18s it won't include
pregnant women it won't include people
that are released from detention under
um the mental health act some of the
people that may well be included in it
though
are some of those that could have been
on that plane that was due to take off
on tuesday to rwanda the first rwanda
deportation flight
as part of that controversial scheme to
move asylum seekers from the uk to
rwanda to have their claims processed
there and to ultimately settle there
clearly controversial though campaigners
say that this is
treating people that are fleeing war and
persecution as if they're criminals but
i think that's really the cornerstone of
the government's approach now because
legislation that's been passed here in
westminster means that if you do come to
the
uk in a small boat or in a lorry then
that legislation essentially means that
you are breaking uh the law so i think
that's why the government think they
have justification um here the labour
leader sakirshama has also been out
campaigning today and talking about this
essentially accusing the government
of a stunt have a listen
i think that the government is chasing
headlines what i want is a serious
response a serious response because
nobody wants these journeys across the
channel to be made these perilous
journeys everybody wants to clamp down
on the gangs that requires grown-up work
with the french authorities and upstream
works to actually tackle these gangs
i think in terms of headline grabbing
accusations sakistama has a point to an
extent the government certainly doesn't
mind us talking about topics like them
fighting in the courts over
flights to rwanda over the electronic
tagging of people that arrive in small
boats
and i think we can get a sense of that
from some of the comments from the home
secretary in the newspapers this morning
accusing the european court of human
rights which of course stopped that
rwanda flight taking off at the last
minute
saying that that decision was scandalous
saying that
accusing the court of being politically
motivated as well so they're clearly
doubling down on this they clearly want
to send out a strong message that they
are at least trying to do something
about
small boats arriving on the south coast
of england and they clearly believe that
they've got
um whilst it will be divisive they
believe that they've got a good chunk of
the public um behind them now i think
the polling on that is more mixed and we
may start to get the first indication
of how much people um are really behind
the government on some of these
so-called wedge issues these
controversial issues that they are
pushing
when we get those by-elections later
this week